and teammate thank you
all right so courses are traditionally
designed only by teachers but classes
impact both students and their future
employers
so what's the solution the co-creation
of courses that cater to the needs of
all three groups welcome to syllabuild
an online tool that allows students and
teachers to build curriculum together
uh that focuses on employer-desired
skills here's the landing page where
students and teachers can both enter
so you can click if you're a student or
if you're a teacher
and
here you see that a teacher can begin to
load in their course content
the title the some of the generic
information um a course description
objectives and then we've included these
comment areas where we would develop
specific questions to draw out student
interests what they hope to learn their
skill sets resources and ideas
as well as critical thinking about
questions they have about the syllabus
so this would allow students to have a
voice in their curriculum as opposed to
just accepting what is offered
so this involvement student involvement
in the process will generate buy-in and
ownership of the course before it's even
begun
okay and students learn a lot of
marketable skills in their courses from
communication skills learning to deal
with ambiguity
um uh
teamwork skills those are very important
but oftentimes these are not explicitly
woven into the course so the system that
we've set up helps teachers weave
marketable skills into the courses that
they're already teaching
and helps teachers think strategically
about the marketing skill sets within
their courses more exciting students
will actually have an opportunity to
connect with employers
because at the end of of the project
they'll do a write-up
and this write-up can include hashtags
of those marketable skills
which employers can then search on
and write comments and reviews we feel
like
the real power is in the intersection of
these viewpoints
and what we can do by all working
together
i have a question
did you consider any ques any things
about copyrights because once they
produce
new elements eventually they can be
copyrighted even by students and so on
as a proposal
so we thought about making
we thought about something kind of
modeled on github where
sort the code is open source so the
projects and the lesson plans that you
have are open source but you can also
choose to make them private so we'd hope
that in general people would want to
make them public so that other
teachers can take the idea and expand
off of them and we could build on the
foundation of creative commons if we so
chose i mean people could make more open
source syllabi that can be shared and
can be flexible
thank you what's the timing for a
student to engage the co-building so if
if um in an ideal world if the class is
starting in the fall and students have
already signed up for classes now they'd
get an email inviting them in but it
could happen any time up until the first
week or so of the class
is the focus high school
we began the conversation with college
but we also realized we we've expanded
it so it would be a parallel process for
high school as well
and part of it would be also cross
institution
sharing resources ideas so um is there a
way that you can get a promise of
teachers unless they've crowdsourced
these ideas that they actually use some
of them is there a benchmark for a
teacher no that she or he did a good
enough job at taking the student
feedback well we're we actually really
are ready to do this this fall so i'm on
board with my course museum studies at
mcla in north adams very good
and partnering with brown and also mit
any more questions
all right thank you